start with the spice coating toast  Szechuan peppercorns and coriander seeds  in a hot dry pan to release their  flavors  add chilli flakes and grind a pestle and  mortar to make a fiery fine powder  combined with plain flour seasoned and  mix add olive oil to a hot pan coat  white bait in the spicy flour mix then  fry  why bait our own oily fish our healthy  delicious and cooking minutes  once golden they're done fantastic with  garlic mayonnaise or a simple squeeze of  lemon  ready in under 10 minutes chili and  spice whitebait an easy simple spicy  dish at brown clothes cinnamon nutmeg  add tahini a nutty paste made from  sesame seeds cooked chickpeas a dash of  lemon juice